tu déconnes ou quoi tpr à [ __ ] en
l'air la mission pour le couvent des
pilos un poète picoleur mieux que toi
avec ta cuvette de chiottes sur la tête
on n'abandonne pas un camarade arles est
peut-être encore en vie c'est pas le
moment de rigoler colonel ces individus
sont dangereux
à en tir 3
qui de vous fait
c'est quoi ça on venait pour te libérer
vous veniez me berry et on avait un plan
d'enfer d'ailleurs si vous voulez j'y
retournais vous appliquez votre plan un
peu vexant home il tarde à l'école blotz
porte
connaissez les rêves
si vous mener la mission à bien vous
obtenez une remise de peine de dix ans
mais si vous me désole ici en quoi que
ce soit
je fais sauter l'engin explosif que vous
avez dans la nuque
alors c'est ça la femme soucy squatteurs
[Musique]
m
y at il des questions
main oui c'est votre main bravo on va
tous mourir
si seulement aux non [ __ ]
alors voila si on fore la mission tu
crèves si on s'aperçoit que tu nous
refile des infos pour y tu crèves si on
s'aperçoit que tu es une et acquiesce
avec un aileron flashy tu crois non
situent tous sans mettre la main devant
la bouche mais que ça ne serve pas d'
excuses pour tous et sans mettre la main
devant la bouche d'accord
c'est quoi le bloc qu'est ce que j'en
sais moi c'est toi le chef est censé
prendre de grandes décisions alors je
décide que tu es bête à bouffer des
kilomètres de pistes si la plage étaient
toutes couvertes de be taken et qu'on me
disait de tout et bouffer pour que la
plage retrouve sa liberté je dirais nos
problèmes en qu'est ce qui peut pousser
quelqu'un à couvrir une plage des pénis
cherche pas c'est un truc de fou
tu suscites
c'est notre spécialité
elle est en fait pas je te sortir de là
vivante chez moi qui vais techart tir de
la vivent
[Applaudissements]
en quelle merde on a un [ __ ] de kaiju
qui font le show
[Musique]
on la pluie c'est comme si une tripotée
dans une logique là dessus